what's under your blanket how's it going
bros my name is this music man oh my
whole body is shaking
are you dancing with me Oh welcome to
three free games the show where I
collect some of the finest most
intellectual pieces of gaming history
today's game is gonna be what's under
your blanket
it's what's questionmark under your
blanket question mark exclamation point
I don't know what that is calling
exclamation point [__] you so if someone
opened the door get up move to the door
and close it move to the bed try not to
get caught okay so here we are
oh man the graphics are so good the
controls are so responsive I love this
bonsai tree over there [__] what he
caught us red-handed what the [__] did I
do I didn't do anything if someone
opened the door get up move to the door
and close it I don't understand let's
just keep wrapping all right this is
[__] cookie clicker they should we
get cookie clicker game out of this now
that'd be quality all right I'm not
gonna pop any more hmmm and the sleeping
man you didn't close the door damn it
just to get a bit sit in a game it oh
man
okay hey grandma Debbie grandma hey
grandma grandma grandma is this awkward
why are you watching this
what's wrong with you halfway there
literally oh I hear someone what do you
want man what is it with parents and
never closing the door all right I never
get it have you both ever been caught
you know doing your thing why maybe your
parents or someone else I haven't no
that never happened to me never have my
mom walked in on me while I was laying
in bed doing my business that does not
happen that is erase from my memory
there's only so fast you can click down
your porn here's the ultimate dilemma
aren't aligned going in such a rant this
is a very dear topic to me so let's say
let's just say in a hypothetical world
work world that has never happened to me
if you are with your pants down doing
your business in front of the computer
and someone comes in what do you do
first do you close the porn or do you
pull up your pants huh what do you do
first
what is worse I don't know oh god we
have a timer I gotta click faster
hey we all have our tricks to get off
okay we only have 30 seconds Jesus
Christ come on baby
think of something good fast monkeys
damn it
ostriches buck up [__] she caught me
red-handed
all right gonna FAP like [__] you
know Neruda new chicks ooh speed
come on can we can we make our penis go
on fire
we're made we're just starting a fight
oh [__] say kitty
goddamn it kitty cat damn it get it get
it get it kitty kitty yeah that's right
okay I mean no kitty look wow what the
[__] is this sweet oh my god I'm
clicking like a [__] boss it's like a
Mario Party days when you have to click
on a [__] I like Pokemon
minigames through muscle strength
it's not about muscle it's about how
fast you can click a mic Mouse here we
go look at this [__] what's with the
great music super flippant bones this
game is all about flipping phones that
away of people's pockets by swinging
your arms so radically you automatically
flip phones keep running keep flipping
flip I got the cab oh [__] oh I smack
the campus I [__] smack the [__] out
of everyone oh [__] I smacked myself -
explosion stop looking at YouTube I mean
keep looking at Peter Pan oh oh that
[__] jumped holy [__] ah what is
this life that I'm living [__] me
Oh God mom mom how do I even okay let's
do one more cuz Jesus Christ I slept all
of you what the [__] are they foes
discharged with [__] bombs what is
this al-qaeda Jesus Christ
okay alright first slapping simulator
then slapping simulator oh my god last
meal man my index finger is way too long
alright so this game is called potato
salad hey I don't want to have this
potato salad you like to have this
potato salad who wants to potato salad
what do I do here is I'm gonna have to
need you want to Fort we use the fork on
the potato salad uh-huh and then we give
it to you hit one of them with that
potato chunk and now you're dead I'm
starting to regret that were just not
keep playing the fapping simulator game
cuz that game was so [__] good why
does the ceiling look like a potato
salad all these questions and so few
answers oh oh we made a distraction what
can we do now oh my god okay
are they potato people if we distract
them and shoot the TV maybe all I can
really do here is fling [__] potato
salad everywhere oh my god oh my god are
you [__] kidding me
oh my god they're so what that [__] this
changes everything
I breathe potato salad
maybe now yes awesome hey what uh I'm
gonna use this a dog the dog won't come
he seemed distracting why is we combine
the sock with the cane and now we can
move the plant hopefully they're looking
at the potato salad hey how you doing
buddy
oh boy this is is this your mom's recipe
and it's
hmm anytime I'm sure the poison will
kick it out of here what do I put it you
seem distracted no he seems dead I'm
pretty sure he ate the potato salad you
want me to die potato salad what is
about to tell me it's [__] this game is
so weird oh my what the [__] are you
doing here and that's just they're still
looking they're still looking we can do
this we can do this we can do this hey
Dawg you went to potato salad eat it eat
it eat it we did it we did it we did it
we did it we did it we did it wow the
blinds seem to our work but they aren't
so what no no no no no [__]
[__] off all right Avery did it okay we
did it [__] you alright bros thank you
so much for watching this video if you
enjoyed give it a thumbs up and I'll see
you bros in the next video and as always
holy moly moly macaroni [__] Jesus
Christ oh my god don't look down